one of those NHS workers is the Labour
MP dr. Rosanna
Alencon she's just finished a night
shift working at st. George's Hospital
in Tooting in London and the A&E
department she joins us now thank you
for talking towards fresh off your night
shift out what have you been doing good
morning well it's been a busy night as
always because we are a busy London
Hospital we are inundated with patients
but what we are seeing is increasingly
more patients coming in who are covered
19 positive so we are very optimistic
that we are an incredible team and we
will do what we have to do to pull
together over the coming weeks but we
are seeing patients coming in in their
30s and 40s who were previously fit and
well without any underlying health
conditions so our message is still to
people please please please observe the
social distancing measures and stay at
home and help us help you it's
interesting that you say that you've
seen people in their thirties people in
their 40s previously fit in well I mean
this perhaps goes against some of the
conceptions that people have of Kovac
19:00 yes I mean it really does and we
were hearing so often that it only
really affects people over 70 it only
really affects people that have
underlying health conditions and that's
why I asked the Prime Minister last week
in Prime Minister's Questions times I
said why are the social distancing
measures merely just suggestions because
what we were seeing echoed on the NHS
front line was the fact that people were
coming in who were young fit and healthy
of course the majority of the patients
will be older those that actually
require ventilation but no single group
of people are immune and the government
of course says it's doing all it can to
keep NHS workers safe the doctors and
nurses the people really on the
frontline of our fight against this
virus is that what you're seeing do NHS
workers have the protective equipment
that they need well in the last few days
in my hospital they have started to
receive the personal protective
equipment and I know that we are very
grateful for that because it does make
us feel safe when we go to work if we
know that we can protect ourselves
potentially stop ourselves getting sick
so that we can
our patients and not spread it to the
ones that we love when we come home but
what we really are concerned about on
the front line and I'm hearing this from
my colleagues around the country is the
fact that we have some very senior
politicians who are saying that they
will return to work after seven days
without knowing how long their symptoms
will last and what we are so concerned
about as health professionals and
something I'm deeply concerned about is
that the advice that we are giving is
actually not in keeping with what the
World Health Organization are saying
they are saying that you can still be
able to spread the virus long after your
symptoms have resolved and they are
actually saying that it is recommended
that you stay self isolated for 14 days
some people they have the disease
process that lasts 12 to 14 days so for
senior politicians such as the prime
minister and the health secretary to
suggest that they will return to work
after seven days is a real worry for
people working in the health sector like
myself because we need to save lives and
we need people to properly observe
self-isolation processes so do you think
in that case then the Prime Minister
who's of course the test and positive
for covert 19 needs to self isolate in
Downing Street for 14 days personally I
believe that the government needs to
change their advice to be in keeping
with what we're seeing around the rest
of the world and what is in keeping with
what the World Health Organization has
said they have said that long after
symptoms resolves one can still be
infectious now if we're doing our very
best to save lives to make sure that no
unnecessary life is lost we have to
ensure that we are sticking to
guidelines that make us able to save
lives and that the virus not to be
spread so I would like Boris Johnson the
prime minister to self isolate for 14
days yes I would and okay well we'll be
putting that to you other people I'm
sure later in the show interesting and
to hear your take on that and now the
case numbers and the daffy numbers are
sadly still going up and are you worried
about how the NHS is going to cope in
weeks ahead as Boris Johnson says he
expects the situation to get worse
before it gets better one thing I am so
proud of being is a part of the NHS
family and about one hour ago I left the
most incredible team of people I know
that we have the resilience to cope with
this we are strong and we will do
whatever it takes to save every single
life we're going to do everything that
we can we can't predict entirely what is
going to happen going forward but what
we can do is save two people please
please stay at home if you can unless
it's absolutely necessary please observe
social distancing measures because we
need you to help us save your life and I
think it's always gonna be a rocky road
going forward I know that we can pull
together this is not about political
point-scoring it's about saying let's
pull together let's work together let's
roll out mass testing so that we know
what we're working with
it worked in South Korea it's done well
in Germany let's roll that mass testing
let let let us really understand what
we're working with and then if people
also observe the social distancing
measures we can save lives and Michael
Gove couldn't quite tell me exactly when
the testing is expected to be rolled out
for all NHS workers although he did say
that the government was ramping up in
the days ahead and how important is that
testing for people who are working in
the health service and do you think it's
been a bit slow coming I'm really
disappointed that we are not able to
test all NHS and care staff at the
moment these are the people who are at
the frontline these are people who need
to know whether or not they have the
virus or not so that if they feel better
if they're feeling poorly they can
return to work and keep working but also
they need to be able to keep their
family safe and their community safe and
I want to see mass testing rolled out as
soon as possible but it is absolutely
urgent that NHS and care staff are
tested and they have access to testing
immediately and I'm not sure it's
entirely fair that senior politicians
are having access to testing or in
frontline NHS staff who will go
into work night shifts day shifts you
know a double shifts at the moment can't
get the test that they need okay dr.
Rosanna Alencon thank you very much for
being thank you very much thank you